the Middle East I mean just historically
speaking was historically good under
Donald Trump I mean it's very difficult
to make de Cas that either before or
after Trump were better than during
Donald Trump the Syrian I don't think
that that Trump contributed to the
Syrian situation improving much um I
think wre he wreck Isis which was in the
I mean Isis had been getting wrecked by
the Kurds in Iraq by every single person
by Assad's Army by Putin by turkey
literally everybody was fighting against
Isis at that point the there's a spike
in violence and then the the Trump I
mean you get credit for when you're
president presumably I mean things got
better with Isis under Trump I mean yeah
they did I mean things got worse with
Isis under Obama they for sure he called
them the JV Squad and then they became
not the JV Squad but is originating in
Syria um and uh baghdaddy and all of the
growth of that is necessarily Obama's
fault I know that we like to say that
Obama created Isis I don't know if you
say that but I've heard that saying a
lot I think that's a little bit
simplistic um I I don't think that
looking at like actions that presidents
have taken the the big the biggest
criticism I have for like Middle Eastern
policy is I think the Doha Accords were
a disaster and I think that's like one
of the biggest blemishes that we have
right now I would also argue that moving
the um Embassy to Jerusalem was also
kind of silly um and arguably
contributed to some of the conflict we
see right now I'll argue precisely the
opposite especially given the fact that
after the movement of the embassy to
Jerusalem the Abraham Accords continued
to sign and actually expand and that if
Donald Trump had been elected I have no
doubt in my mind that Saudi Arabia would
now be a part of the Abraham Accords in
fact that was basically pre-negotiated
uh and then when Joe Biden took office
Joe Biden took a very anti-saudi stance
on a wide variety of issues the the
biggest single effect in the Middle East
of Joe Biden's presidency and again I
agree with you that not every foreign
policy issue can be laid at the hands of
a President Joe Biden's main approach to
the Middle East was very similar to the
Obama approach which is why the Middle
East was chaotic under Obama and chaotic
under Biden and that was to alienate
allies like Saudi Arabia and Israel and
instead to try to make common cause or
cut deals with Iran what that did is
incentivize terrorism from Iran what
we're watching in the Middle East is
Iran attempting to use every one of its
Terror proxies in the Middle East and it
was specifically launched in an attempt
to avoid what Biden actually was trying
to do which was good which was after two
years of failure with Saudi Arabia try
to bring them into the Abraham Accords
right that was what was burgeoning at
the end of La at the end of last year
and Iran saw that and Iran decided that
they were going to throw a grenade into
the middle of those negotiations by
essentially activating Hamas Hamas
activates Hamas commits October 7th
Israel as a sovereign nation state has
to respond to the murder of 1200 of its
citizens and the taken kidnapping of of
240 Israel has to do that not only to go
after its own hostages and try to
restore them but also to reestablish
military deterrence in the most violent
region of the world hisbah gets active
on Israel's northern border hisbah is an
Iranian proxy they get active on the
northern border the the hthis in Yemen
get active these are all the only reason
all this is happening at the same time
is because Iran is doing this right not
just that they're they are threatening
global Shipping if you're talking about
the effects of global supply lines which
I totally age had a major inflationary
effect on the economy thanks to right
now the cost of shipping is nearly
double what it was just a few weeks ago
and that is because a ragtag group of
hthi Barbarians are attacking
international shipping and forcing
everybody to stop using the Babel M
Freight instead going around the Cape of
Good Hope in in Africa all of that is
the result of the fact that Joe Biden
reoriented the United States in the very
early days in favor of a more Pro
Iranian stance he appointed Robert Mali
to negotiate the Iran deal who as it
turns out was using proxy
many of his AIDS were actually taking
money from Iran the the the Biden
Administration literally one of their
first acts was to delist the hoodies as
a terror organization and sanctions
against the hoodies these are all moves
that that Biden made very early on they
were disastrous moves but when it comes
to domestic policy I think he hasn't
been nearly as dam domastic on fore sure
sure so just on a couple of Middle
Eastern things so one of the big things
that threw the Middle East into disaster
was we all traumatized by it now was the
Iraq evasion which under Republican
president sure agree that right the the
deposition of Saddam Hussein and
everything that followed after probably
contributed more to the growth of Isis
and the destabilization of that entire
region probably more than anything else
I think that under prior to Bush um for
Clinton and even at the beginning of
Bush's presidency we were on some kind
of road to normaly um with Iran which I
think has to happen whether we like them
or not um until Bush for whatever reason
decides to throw Iran into the axis of
Evil and that we're on a road to normaly
with Iran in the 1990s we do in the wait
what that we're on a road to normaly
with Iran in the 1990s my understanding
is that yeah from the late 9s and prior
to the Access of Evil labeling of Iran
that there was going to be some path
forward to where we could start to
normalize relationships with them I I I
find that very difficult to believe and
I don't see a lot of evidence I mean we
can just disagree on that okay yeah sure
we can disagree on that but I know that
once the after effects just quick note
the after effect of the Iraq war that
was the most devastating was the
increase in power of Iran I agree yeah
because of the destabilization of Iraq
and Iraq not having a uh a government
there that was functional for at least a
decade and was in fact Sunni government
right originally it was Sunni government
disbanding the the Sunni Army was one of
the worst things that the Bush
Administration diding all the former B
part yeah all horrible under Republican
president um but don't disagree that the
uh yeah that that probably contributed
more to Isis uh to the growth of power
in Iran maybe even to the decivilization
of Syria probably more than anything
that Obama
did